France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe nous sommes ici à
Sofia capitale de la Bulgarie dans le
très beau musée archéologique témoin de
la culture millénaire bulgare une
Bulgarie qui néanmoins en ce moment
s'interroge pendant longtemps jusqu'à la
guerre en Ukraine à la Russie était
perçue de façon positive en raison de sa
proximité linguistique et religieuse
aujourd'hui ce petit pays balkanique de
6 millions 500 000 habitants et le plus
pauvre de lieu est connu une crise
politique en raison d'un mouvement
russophile et d'un parti de droite qui
prend le devant de la scène 14% aux
dernières élections le parti guerre donc
partie de Monsieur Boris sauf et
confronté à une courte majorité et a du
mal à former une coalition avec son
adversaire change le changement continu
du Premier ministre petcov et nous en
parlons tout de suite avec la
vice-présente Bulgare il y en ayotova
bonjour je rappelle que vous êtes proche
plutôt des socialistes vous êtes surtout
vice-présidente comment sortir de cette
crise politique en deux ans nous avons
cinq scrutins parlementaires pour un
pays comme la Bulgarie c'est trop je
voudrais vous raconter un peu sur la
situation de énergétique parce que c'est
très important les crises énergétiques
sont les crises les plus importantes les
plus lourdes parce que ça reposait à
chacun individu à chaque famille vous
voyez nous parlons d'abord d'un pays qui
dépendait tout le temps du gaz russe du
Gazprom il y a quelques mois le gaz a
été interrompu nous n'avons pas aucune
possibilité d'avoir de contrats de long
terme et la connexion avec la graisse
à rester une cheville
rien que au cours de quelques de
quelques mois le gouvernement
intérimaire de du président de la
République à sécuriser
l'approvisionnement du gaz et à réduire
les fruit du carburant c'est très
important non seulement pour les
entreprises mais pour les consommateurs
même si vous dépendez toujours beaucoup
du pétrole même presque entièrement du
pétrole Bitcoin russe la situation a
changé déjà parce que à la connexion
avec la Grèce et déjà réelle aussi on a
augmenté la connexion et le terminal en
alexandreuropolis pour le gaz à lucifié
et je vais mentionner quelque chose qui
est très important
la Bulgarie et le seul pays qui a un
contrat pour l'utiliser l'infrastructure
gazières de la Turquie maintenant c'est
la vraie la réelle diversification parce
que les réseaux les sources sont très
différentes mais c'est le même chose
avec l'énergie nucléaire c'est le même
principe on était tout à fait dépendant
du
combustible nucléaire russe maintenant
on a conclu les contrats les accords
avec Framatome et
et c'est aussi avec la diversification
avec la France parce que vous savez que
la France et la bulgarine défendons la à
l'énergie nucléaire parce que au
contraire nous ne pouvons pas atteindre
les objectifs de la des carbone de
carbonisation alors parlons quand même
de ce parti prorus 14% au dernières
élections un an après l'invasion de
l'Ukraine qu'est-ce que ça traduit de
votre société et qui bloque le
géopolitique parce que finalement on
n'arrive pas à constituer de majorité
c'est pas seulement les idées produits
je pense que à ce parti ils expriment le
vote négatif du peuple parce que j'ai
dit déjà que
le vent du rejet le vent du rejet le
ventre négatif ainsi un jour il y a un
autre partie qui qui va exprimer sur
votre négative sur votre rejet ils vont
je puisse avoir beaucoup plus de
pourcentage alors la question des
livraisons d'armes à l'Ukraine est
devenu un sujet sensible la vulgarie ne
livre pas de munitions et d'armes
officiellement mais en fait
officieusement elle le fait via la
Roumanie la Pologne le Royaume-Uni les
États-Unis est-ce que ce n'est pas un
peu ambigu tout d'abord la position
nationale
nous étions le seul pays qui était le
premier au premier heures de réinvasion
de la guerre Russo Ukraine le président
a
invité et à l'uni les représentants de
toutes les institutions bulgares et on a
défini notre position nationale c'est un
acceptable au 20e siècle de déployer et
de piloter des bombardiers et des
missiles stratégiques au cœur de
l'Europe contre un pays tout à fait à
souverain et voilà pourquoi
notre pays à la Bulgarie va participer
dans tous les formats de le temps pour
afin de d'avoir une résolution d'une
solution du conflit mais en même temps
vous voyez que vous êtes contre la
livraison des armes non nous ne sommes
pas contre les livraison des armes parce
que je voudrais mentionner que nous
avons une déclaration du Parlement
bulgare d'envoyer des armes en Ukraine
avec bien sûr les spécificités que nous
avons ici en Bulgarie les armes qui nous
que nous avons et
on a suggéré beaucoup de choses mais la
vérité c'est que nous sommes membres
loyal de l'Union européenne et la
politique de défense la politique de
sécurité est la même en Bulgarie en
Roumanie et les autres pays vous êtes je
lisez socialiste proche du président
roman radef il est régulièrement c'est
un ancien militaire il est régulièrement
accusé ici d'être
plutôt pro russe de peut-être avoir
sentir un destin personnel justement de
vouloir diriger précisément plus le
gouvernement parce qu'il avec ses
gouvernements par intérim il a plus de
pouvoir est-ce que pour vous c'est le
cas voilà j'ai parlé déjà des étiquettes
et des idéologies le conflit en Ukraine
éloigne malheureusement l'idée d'une
défense européenne
je sais que dans le bossol stratégique
il y a un certain développement mais
c'est insuffisant en ce moment-là il
convient de réfléchir sur les propos de
Monsieur Macron le président de la
France pour une plus grande autonomie de
l'Europe une plus grande souveraineté en
Europe et de défendre notre continent
aussi comme un membre de l'air d'automne
mais aussi d'avoir une défense propre
votre président n'est pas ambigu sur la
Russie
le président a une position tout à fait
nationale c'est-à-dire nationale
européenne Bulgarie 300 000 russes
possèdent 500 000 propriétés à titre
individuel
les sanctions individuelles est-ce
qu'elle s'applique pleinement justement
sur ces individus russes autant en
Bulgarie qu'ailleurs
la Bulgarie a se tenue de tous les
sanctions imposées à la Russie jusqu'à
ce moment-là sauf peut-être
les sanctions futures qui vont concerner
l'énergie nucléaire parce que au
contraire ça signifiera que nous
devons fermer notre centrale nucléaire
on ne peut pas
permettre on réfléchit à interdire les
importations de céréales
ukrainiennes pour avoir laissé passer
des céréales par un corridor qui devait
aller à d'autres pays vous demandez
quand même 16 millions d'euros à la
Commission européenne parce qu'elles ont
été stockées sur votre sur votre sol les
agriculteurs disent qu'il y a eu des
problèmes de baisse des prix et qu'elles
sont bon marché et peut-être avec des
pesticides est-ce que vous allez
interdire les céréales ukrainiennes la
bulgarine n'est pas le seul pays nous
avons déjà une coalition informelle avec
la Slovaquie avec la Roumanie avec la
Pologne et je pense que c'est nécessaire
et il faut que
la Commission européenne soit prudente
ici et avoir élaborer une décision
commune alors 15 ans de présence de la
Bulgarie dans l'Union européenne disant
de gouvernement de droite du guerbe
justement on pense à Monsieur Boyko
Borisov beaucoup de fonds structurels
mais un rattrapage qui n'est pas
totalement opéré parce qu'il y a quand
même vous êtes quand même encore par pi
par habitant à 55%
[Musique]
la corruption les États-Unis et le
Royaume-Uni ont sanctionné par exemple
des anciens ministres de Monsieur
Borisov pour corruption notamment
concernant l'énergie pourquoi est-ce que
justement cette lutte anticorruption que
demande le peuple il est descendu dans
la rue d'ailleurs elle n'a pas été bien
parachevée c'est un grand problème pour
toute l'Europe et pour tout le monde
mais il faut que ces gens-là vont être
sanctionnés pour les institutions
nationales non seulement pour magnit qui
est les autres commissions c'est une
législation américaine qui qui n'a pas
aucune aucune conséquence ici en
Bulgarie vous voyez et l'Union
européenne elle s'inquiète de
d'oligarques un oligarque qui en fait
aurait touché des fonds européens en
l'occurrence à mauvais escient qu'il
doit rembourser c'est ça et vous voyez
il y a déjà un parquet au niveau
européen il y a des parquets ici en
Bulgarie ce sont des institutions
indépendantes ils doivent faire son
travail
vous avez perdu 10% de votre population
dans les 10 dernières années les écarts
se sont un peu creusés d'ailleurs entre
les plus pauvres et les plus riches
comment post pandémie bien ramener cette
population remédier à cette exode vers
les autres pays de l'Union européenne
premier priorité c'est la célébrité du
pays et le développement de l'économie
nous avons une très belle nouvelle parce
que pour la première fois nous avons un
investisseur stratégique à la Bulgarie
devient une vraie pépinière avec une
zone industrielle bien développée pour
pour la production des composants
automobiles des accessoires pour les
voitures
ça n'était jamais dans notre pays le
développement de l'économie l'éducation
bien sûr de l'éducation au niveau
européens
les services aussi le santé
toutes ces choses sont des arguments qui
qui obligent les jeunes de rester en
Bulgarie sont obligés les jeunes parlons
de votre entrée dans la zone euro qui
était une grande question d'ailleurs qui
qui devait avoir lieu à en 2024 est
repoussé en raison de la crise politique
pour 2025 votre partie socialiste
d'ailleurs n'était pas très enthousiaste
est-ce que les Bulgares ils sont
favorables c'est le gouvernement du
Parti socialiste qui n'est pas d'accord
je suis pas sûr pour les pour les
membres de ce parti je pense que la
majorité des du peuple la majorité des
citoyens burgers
ils ont certains des herbes pour pour
les raisons non pas parce qu'ils sont
contre leur heure mais parce que ils
n'ont pas assez d'informations ils ont
peur que les prix des produits vont se
lever ils ont peur que ils vont perdre
les avoir dans les banques
et voilà pourquoi c'est la tâche du
gouvernement de faire une une campagne
pour expliquer et pour informer les
citoyens
qu'est-ce qui va se passer un jour quand
la Bulgarie sera membre de zone Europe
je pense que
nous devons aussi accomplir tous les
critères du Maastricht et de diminuer de
réduire l'inflation qui est déçu de
retard finalement vous à titre personnel
deux ans deux ans c'est bien
entrer dans l'espace Schengen là ça
aussi c'est assez crucial et c'est
bloqué cette fois-ci par les Pays-Bas
qui jugent qu'il y a une forte trop
forte immigration illégale et puis aux
frontières vous devez faire la police
parfois ça ça donne lieu à des
affrontements
frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne 130 km avec la Turquie et
vous avez demandé deux milliards obtenus
600 millions de la commission pour cette
frontière est-ce que vous espérez une
entrée dans Schengen et pour quelle date
chaque fois
partager soulevé ce sujet et cette
question à chaque nouvelle présidente du
conseil
et je pense que pour la Bulgarie et la
Roumanie il y a deux poids de mesures
qu'on appelle souvent double standard
parce que nous avons satisfait nous
avons accompli à tous les critères
techniques tous les critères techniques
qui étaient nécessaires à l'époque pour
les autres pays qui sont déjà membres de
l'espace Schengen mais vous voyez que
chaque fois il y a des problèmes il y a
des considérations il y a des conditions
dans certains pays membres ce sont avant
tout des conditions internes politiques
par exemple dans certains pays il y a
des élections il y a on peut pas trouver
une balance entre les partis politiques
il y a d'autres problèmes et voilà
pourquoi c'est c'est toujours la
Bulgarie et la Roumanie qui vont dans un
rôle de bouc émissaire
je pense que on doit finir avec cette
double standard
en plus dans une moment où l'Europe est
en guerre
et à la guerre ravage le cœur d'Europe
il faut que on change les citoyens et
les partenaires européens ils doivent
penser à une autre manière parce que
nous avons maintenant la nécessité
d'avoir une Europe plus forte et des
citoyens plus solidaires quand il s'agit
de la frontière Burgard c'est la
frontière extérieure de l'Union la
frontière avec la Turquie je pense que
c'est c'est la frontière la plus sur
maison parce qu'à l'époque quand j'étais
membre du Parlement européen j'étais
dans certains pays en Italie en Malte en
Grèce et j'avais la possibilité de voir
qu'est-ce qui se passe là-bas maintenant
la frontière est sûre ah oui nous devons
recevoir d'argent de plus de fonds
européens parce que les flux migratoires
ont augmenté le dernier jour le dernier
semestre le dernier mois il faut qu'on
sécurise la frontière et en plus vous
voyez il y a déjà une décennie à toute
la législation européenne qui concerne
la migration les réfugiés et en retard
c'est pas une bon étiquette pour
l'Europe n'est-ce pas merci à vous en
tout cas d'avoir répondu à cette
question madame la vice-présidente
depuis Sofia merci à vous restez en
notre compagnie pour le débat avec
public Sénart dans quelques minutes au
Parlement européen
[Musique]
bienvenue au Parlement européen pour
notre débat autour de la vision
géopolitique du président français
Emmanuel Macron fait-il cavalier seul
vis-à-vis de ses 26 partenaires du club
européen en défendant une souveraineté
européenne trop française pour faire
l'unanimité affaibli par une
impopularité grandissante à domicile
agrégens 70% de mécontents suite à sa
réforme des retraites Emmanuel Macron
étant en temps faire de la France une
puissance d'équilibre capable d'incarner
une troisième voie et à son retour de
Pékin il a semblé se placer du côté de
la Chine en affirmant qu'il ne fallait
pas être suiviste sur Taïwan et
s'adapter au rythme américain cette
déclaration a mis à mal l'alliance des
Occidentaux face à la Chine à affaibli
Taïwan et elle a été critiquée par nos
voisins européens le en même temps
macronie est-il véritablement applicable
à la diplomatie on en parle tout de
suite avec un Roumain justement
Christian Silvio bousoy euro député du
Parti populaire européen ici
effectivement à Bruxelles et en espagnol
député du Parti réunion qui est celui de
renaissance le parti macroniste avec un
discours de la Sorbonne et un premier
mandat en fanfare sous les drapeaux
européens et Emmanuel Macron
apparaissait comme cette européen
convaincu qui voulait aussi convaincre
ses partenaires d'une vraie diplomatie
finalement très autonome est-ce que
l'histoire lui a donné raison il a
réussi à l'être si on doit être allié et
on est et on doit garder c'est-à-dire
une politique comment ça signifie qu'il
faut la coordination par la
subordination et il y a un pilier qui
c'est clair notre ambition de la France
et l'Union européenne et de Etats-Unis
c'est la même les status quo à Taïwan
doit être pas touchées par dépression
quoi qu'il soit alors à ce niveau c'est
clair de ce guidisme c'est pas la
solution c'est la coordination entre le
singulier les autres je crois que
l'Europe doit comprendre que on peut pas
continuer à être une grande ventre avec
un petit tête alors justement lors de ce
voyage en Chine Emmanuel Macron il avait
emmené Ursula vanderleyen en disant
c'est plus européen et ce qu'il est
resté sur cette ligne européenne j'étais
un peu étonné des déclarations parce que
bien sûr connaissant la position de la
France de protéger le statut la
déclaration à faibli est divise à
diviser l'Europe et bien sûr il y a un
risque aussi l'appui de l'Europe dans
des États-Unis soit en question c'est
pour ça que
on doit rester très bien coordonnées
très unis sur les questions de l'Ukraine
de Taïwan autrement on fait on peut
créer des confusions et on peut donner
des signals mal signal à la Chine d'agir
là et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
veut pas donc
on peut bien sûr parler d'une Europe
plus forte on peut bien parler d'une
relation plus efficace avec les
États-Unis dans les questions
économiques on peut avoir aussi des
choses qu'on peut discuter qui ne sont
pas d'accord sur les questions
économiques mais sur la sécurité
l'Europe et les États-Unis sont les plus
importants à liés les pays qui partagent
des valeurs communes partager ces
partager pas devenir les grands frères
et les petits frères si on arrive à voir
qu'est-ce que ça passe dans le scénario
le plus proche de la Chine que c'est le
Pacifique on peut rentrer dans les aku
c'est à dire comment et les États-Unis
d'infection unilatérale ils sont fait
une axe
stratégique que c'est les United Kingdom
c'est là Australie et c'est les
États-Unis
qui a pas réussi à le faire etc
la France il y a une présence très
importante plus importante encore que
les United
au Pacifique comment on peut comprendre
une stratégie pour faire face aux défis
chinois sans la France alors la première
des questions c'est celle-là comment les
États-Unis sont en train de faire des
actions ouilatérales une pensant que
tous les autres vont les suivre alors la
coordination c'est la coordination pas
la soumission à cet égard je crois que
Macron il a mis le doigt sur les points
concrètes et réaliste c'est quand même
un peu traditionnel de la France vous
savez bien le général de Gaulle disait
déjà ne pas s'aligner sur les Américains
c'est peut-être intéressant que la
France le dise d'autant qu'on est pas
sûr que que en 2024 ça ne soit pas
Donald Trump qui se désinvestisse à
nouveau beaucoup de l'Europe par exemple
Donald Trump n'est plus président et
peut-être ne sera jamais encore
président maintenant avec la nouvelle
administration les relations entre les
l'Union européenne et les États-Unis
sont très bonnes sur plusieurs chambres
même sur l'accord de Paris sur le
changement climatique sur les
coopérations économiques on peut
améliorer comme j'avais dit mais c'est
pas le sujet de notre dialogue
aujourd'hui mais maintenant nous avons
une autre réalité aussi en Europe c'est
l'invasion l'agression de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine ou l'appui le support
américain c'est très important pour
l'Europe et pour les pays de centre et
l'est d'Europe et président Macron qui
est une vraie leader européenne aussi
s'exprime pas seulement au nom de la
France mais qu'il quand ils disent
quelque chose
sur le plan géopolitique il parle un peu
sur l'Europe aussi dans le nombre de
l'Europe aussi et vous avez vu la
réaction dans quelques pays européens
pour le nid mon pays Roumanie et
d'autres capitales européennes qui ont
critiqué le moment et les déclaration S
qui n'ont pas un vrai sens parce que je
crois pas que les États-Unis vont faire
des actions dans le Pacifique sans ses
coordonnées et sans demander les Alliés
européennes est-ce que je précisément
d'accord ça justement c'est ce dont on
parlait en éjectant aussi la France de
ce de cette initiative Emmanuel Macron
des canards en 2019 c'était au moment de
Trump justement que l'OTAN est en mort
cérébrale aujourd'hui on voit que de
nombreux pays frappent à sa porte vu de
l'Est de l'Europe vu de du nord de
l'Europe c'est devenu quelque chose de
très important l'OTAN est-ce que c'est
une erreur finalement qui les déclaré ça
comme moi j'écoutais la déclaration des
présidents Macron sur les la mort
cérébrale Dieu n'était pas d'accord avec
lui je crois dire que il s'est trompé
mais encore s'il s'est trompé pas et la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est tout différent
pourquoi la sonnette a été
revivifier à nous tous pour commencer à
prendre sérieusement notre défense comme
une défense avec une autonomie et
stratégique que ça signifie pas du tout
un déconnexion
c'est-à-dire les autant c'est la
capitale bah ça signifie pas que on doit
être toujours un petit on peut dire les
petits frères juste quoi et dernièrement
c'est toujours le S américain qui sont
cherchés de notre défense c'est un grand
erreur de côté européen il faut que
chacune il y a une véritable
c'est-à-dire et protagoniste de même
avec nos Saliers et nos salines
neutralier les principales c'est les
États-Unis allier ça signifie allié
logiquement les États-Unis sont les
forces de dissuration
et atomique
d'Emmanuel Macron s'appelait pas
beaucoup de pays enfin est-ce que
beaucoup de pays sont séduits par cette
idée d'autonomie stratégique et défend
européenne attention quand on parle de
la
stratégie de la autonomie et stratégique
ça signifie pas la couper des relations
c'est-à-dire les États-Unis sont une
autonomie et stratégique n'est-ce pas
alors pourquoi on doit penser que on
doit toujours être dessus
un allié et n'étant réaliers les plus
importants qu'il y en a à lire ça
signifie coordination ça signifie
l'histoire
européenne est-ce que c'est vrai oui les
Européens à la défense européenne nous
avons voté cette semaine à Parlement
européenne et une projet pour faire des
achats ensemble aussi nous avons
quelques initiatives sur la défense
l'autonomie stratégique c'est une
question que on doit discuter
sérieusement nous ne posons pas à ça
mais en même temps la relation avec les
États-Unis et le fondement absolu de
notre sécurité donc si il y a quelque
chose s'il y a en crainte que les
États-Unis vont actionner dans la
question de Taïwan sans nous consulter
la France et la les États-Unis ont une
relation excellent le président Macron
le président parle beaucoup c'était pas
une une idée
très bonne de dire en public de dire en
Chine de faire cette déclarations qui
crée des confusions qui ont
l'Europe l'ambassadeur de Chine en
France est allé dire dans la foulée que
peut-être que la Russie avait des
revendications légitimes sur les Pays
Basque qui sont donc membres de l'Union
on peut pas dire nous ne pouvons pas
dire que c'était une
à la suite de la déclaration de la
présidente de la France qui sont un peu
vieux opportunité pour faire ces
déclarations mais c'est une déclaration
très mauvaise et bien sûr on doit être
très clair sur ces questions sur la
question de la Chine aussi c'est pas
mauvais c'est un bêtises et la bêtise
c'est le suivant et on peut parler des
Tibet alors les Tibet c'était une
situation de independence jusqu'à
approximatif dans le cycle 17 encore
la Mongolie est une partie de la Chine
jusqu’à 1920 quelques et encore il y a
des traités entre la Russie qui a pris
des parties des territoires chinois je
ne crois pas que la Chine va faire
l'invasion de la Russie prochainement
alors qu'est-ce qui a fait le
l'ambassadeur de la Chine à Paris
c'était pas une erreur c'est vraiment
c'est une des plus grands bêtises que
j'ai écouté dans ma vie mais
reconnu
elle possède l'arme nucléaire elle a le
3e réseau diplomatique mondiale après la
Chine et les États-Unis Emmanuel Macron
il a fait bouger les lignes en Europe
notamment sur des plans de relance
commun sur la livraison d'armes à
l'Ukraine sur cette idée d'autonomie
stratégique est-ce que est-ce que les
européens reconnaissent ou est-ce que
maintenant finalement il est un hors sol
et il n'est plus connecté non les
Européens
de président Macron et de la France sont
bien venus même dans le domaine de
défense c'est pas seulement le plan de
relance économique
le changement climatique l'accord de
Paris tout ça sont très importants et la
France est totalement soutenue par par
les autres pays de l'Europe mais sur les
questions de sécurité dans le contexte
de l'Ukraine dans le contexte que la
Chine a grandi la répression de la
politique interne est un peu sur la
politique extérieure est plus plus
engagé fait des exercices militaires
très proches de Taïwan ces sortes de
déclaration de distance ça c'était
quelque chose qu'on peut pas comprendre
alors je rappelle que vous êtes de du
même parti et raviarnaert mais est-ce
que finalement avec un Emmanuel Macron
qui est affaibli sur la scène intérieure
70% de mes comptes sur sa réforme des
retraites est-ce que c'est ça qui fait
que c'est plus difficile pour lui aussi
d'apparaître comme un grand leader
européen parce que dans votre pays on a
parlé des manifestations dans tous les
pays on a parlé finalement de cette
Emmanuel Macron très affaiblis qui n'a
pas de majorité non plus
[Musique]
il y a des mondes que va croire que la
guerre entre la
Urani et la Russie ça va signifier la
défaite de la Russie en effet on est
capable de croire que la Russie que
c'est impuissance atomique va être
vaincu par une puissance avec un courage
immense que c'est le courage de le
peuple crânien canon parle de la guerre
il faut parler de après la guerre
canon il faut voir que sera le suivi et
la sortie de cette guerre et parfois
dire des sources qui sont réalistes
c'est pas des tout c'est à dire
acceptable
vous entendez ce que dit Javier Narc
Emmanuel Macron et il pense déjà à la
pré il a des positions plus réalistes
notamment sur la l'Ukraine ou les pays
en effet de l'est souvent disent il faut
absolument que cette guerre soit gagnée
la Russie vaincue et à terre et quand
lui finalement a une position où il dit
il ne faut pas humilier les Russes
bon sur l'Ukraine bien sûr il y a des
noix entre les pays européens les pays
de l'Est les pays Baltique mon pays
Roumanie polonais peut-être sont plus
enthousiastes à voir à soutenir avec
tous les coups les Ukrainiens de
défendre la Russe par la Russie parce
que c'était une agression inacceptable
on peut pas dire le nom quel sera
l'avenir mais
les déclarations sur la Chine encore une
fois c'est très difficile à comprendre
parce que Emmanuel Macron est le leader
politique la personnalité politique de
l'Europe la plus reconnue dans le monde
il y a pas une autre personnalité
politique maintenant avec la force de
Emmanuel Macron et la reconnaissance
autour de moi encore une fois s'il est
des craintes de suspicions qu'on va
faire des questions qui sont pas de bon
à l'égard à l'égard le Taïwan il a une
bonne relation pour discuter ça
bilatéralement et une formule avec les
États-Unis je ne sais pas quel résultat
positif de ces déclarations je crois
qu'il y a plus de bruit que de réalité
la réalité c'est que l'engagement de la
France de l'Europe indire et des
États-Unis c'est clair et net et tout le
monde se fait pétit de minorité qu'il
faut vraiment négliger on est tous
d'accord que on ne sera solidaire avec
le granit et que on donnera tous les
supports que et mérité est-ce que ça
c'est la réalité et c'est à dire et
exprimer des sources et croire que cette
guerre aura pas un suivi militaire mais
un suivi politique ça c'est une réalité
est-ce que finalement on peut dire
d'Emmanuel Macron qu'il est surtout pas
diplomate et un peu isolé de des autres
pays européens du coup sur cette
déclaration peut dire ça aussi mais bon
regardons l'ensemble c'est clair que
Emmanuel Macron est une vraie
personnalité beaucoup d'entre nous le
suivons dans beaucoup des initiatives
c'est pour ça que beaucoup d'entre nous
étaient étonnés de cette déclaration qui
était la première que je vois très
difficile à comprendre merci à vous
d'avoir très bien illustré finalement
cette vision du président français merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis pour ici
l'Europe vous restez sur nos antennes
France 24 et Public Sénat pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]